[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in one of the stars of
football night in america
also uh the color analyst for notre dame
football tony dungy
how surprising is that tone that uh you
know the cowboys are ratings gold
unbelievable i don't think we've ever
done this before dan and uh
it was a little bit of a shock to the
system but i tell you one guy who's
happy your man justin dungey
is the biggest browns fan in the world
he's got his baker mayfield jersey
all this brown stuff ready to go for
next sunday this is uh tony's son who
would always be there in the hallways
when i would go in on sunday for
football night in america
he'd have his gloves on receivers gloves
on and he would just play
whoever would throw the football to him
my best to uh justin i hope he's doing
well
uh what do you expect tonight with the
rams and the patriots
it's going to be interesting because as
you know bill belichick
is famous and does a great job of taking
away what you do best
for the rams that's aaron donald rushing
the passer
and then offensively all the quick
movement
jet sweep bootlegs all of that i think
they're going to try to make jared goff
stay in the pocket
uh it's going to be an interesting game
a strategy game
last time we saw these two teams in the
super bowl
bill belichick definitely got the best
of it but
explain that to me all those years that
you coached against belichick
you know he's going to try to take away
what did he try to take away from your
colts teams when you faced him
well for us for a long time it was the
deep passing game and
i joke with rodney harrison we played a
game against them in 2004
we ran the same play inside belly to the
right
12 straight times took it all the way
down the field and scored
he didn't change defenses he said is
peyton manning going to be patient
enough
we had to learn that and be patient and
run the ball
then in the championship game when we
were down we had to drive to win the
game
he played the same coverage he was not
going to let marvin harrison beat him we
threw every ball in that drive to the
left side reggie wayne
dallas clark on the left brian fletcher
on the left
because he was not going to let marvin
harrison on the right beat him
and we had to learn that we had to go in
and peyton would tell
our guys our brian fletchers and reggie
wayne's
you're gonna have a big day today
because that's the way the game is gonna
go
it's interesting though every team knows
that bill's going to do this
and i think he's done a really good job
coaching this year because i don't think
they're good at
all and we don't i mean cam is probably
more dangerous as a runner than a passer
but if you're belichick have you seen
enough of cam
that you know what your decision is
going to be at the end of the year on
is he going to be your quarterback i
think it really depends on how this
plays out if they continue to win
and make the playoffs and make some
noise in the playoffs then he says yeah
i can build around cam newton
uh get me some other weapons that kind
of go with this build an offense
like baltimore get those defenders back
who opted out for covet
and yeah we could do some damage next
year because we're not that far away
would you want to coach a running
quarterback
i i wouldn't mind because i think what
it does
is when you play other teams they are
off kilter they're all scheduled
they've gotten ready to defend all this
passing game
and now when when you defend baltimore
lamar jackson it's a totally different
package
and a lot of people can't adjust like
that a few good defensive coaches can
but most people can't so
i think you have a little advantage
would you rather have a great drop back
pastor or
a great running quarterback i i think in
this day and age you want the great
passer
because those guys are hard to stop
patrick mahomes with the way the rules
are
you aren't really going to be able to
stop him you got to hope he has an off
day
you know you can load up on lamar
jackson and we're going to take away the
run now he's got to have a great day
throwing the ball to beat us
but it is so easy to throw the ball now
i think that's what everybody's looking
for
i want you to be honest and i know you
always are sometimes to your detriment
you kill me with that you you're
when you were coaching were you a faster
runner than peyton manning
uh not my last couple of years i think
maybe when i was 48 or 49 when i got
there but by time i was 52
at the end of the day no he could beat
me are you sure
i think so when we ran off the field
after the super bowl he beat me to the
locker room
we're talking to tony dungy the hall of
famer uh football night america analyst
and uh now you're working with the
texans
on trying to help them find a general
manager
is that right no don't don't start that
rumor dan okay here's what happened okay
al mcnair
called several people and said would you
talk to me about
how to select a general manager and a
head coach
okay and i said sure i would love to
well all of a sudden that becomes you're
on a committee
to select the next gentleman i've had 50
million
texts from people uh who want this job
head coach or gm
i am not picking the person all i'm
doing is giving
mr mcnair a formula and what i told him
dan is the same thing
you and i have talked about for years i
said first of all build your blueprint
and tell me what you want then i can
give you some suggestions
but don't come to me and say who's good
i have 50 people that i'd love to hire
but they're not going to work for me and
it doesn't matter what i think of them
you have to decide what you want and
todd i would tell
coach that just thank you